والذين صبروا ابتغاء وجه ربهم واقاموا
الصلاه وانفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا
وعلانيه وانفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا وعلانيه
ويدرؤون بالحسنه السيئه اولئك لهم عقب
الدار جنات عدن يدخلونها ومن صلح من
ابائهم واز
وذرياتهم والملائكه يدخلون عليهم من كل
باب سلام عليكم بما صبرتم فنعم عقب
الدار في هذه الايات الله سبحانه وتعالى
يطنب في ذكري ويستطرد
في
صفات اهل
العلم من عباده
انما يخشى الله من
عباده
العلماء والعلماء
هنا
المقصود
بهم الذين
يعلمون ان الله
واحد وانه مستحق للعباده
وحده ويستجيبون
لله والعلماء من بين هؤلاء العلماء وهم
العلماء في لغتنا من باب
اولى
العالم في لغه القران
والسنه انما هو الذي يعمل
بعلمه الذي يحفظ كثيرا ويفقه كثيرا ويفهم
كثيرا ويدبر كثيرا ويحفظ ظ
المناقشات والاستطراد
و يكثر
اضطلاعه
ولكن ليس له عمل بذلك العلم فهذا لا يطلق
عليه اسم العالم في القران
والسنه انما يطلق عليه اسم الجاهل هذا
جاهل فالذي لا يعلم
بعلمه مهما بلغ من المعلومات من الحفظ
والاتقان فانه يكون جاهلا عند
الله
و هذا كثيرا نجده في
القران وفي السنه
كذلك روى ابن عبد
البر رحمه الله تعالى في كتابه الحافل فضل
العلم يقول
يقول روى في كتابه عن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم انه
قال انما يحمل هذا العلم من
كل من كل قوم عدول او من كل جيل
عدوله
والمقصود لمن صحح هذه الروايه ان الذين
يحملون العلم ويعملون به هم اهل العدل من
امه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم واما غيرهم
مهما بلغ من المعلومات والحفظ فانه ليس
عالما قال بنو
اسرائيل لموسى عليه السلام اتتخذنا
هزوا قال اعوذ بالله ان اكون من
الجاهلين لانه يكون بالس استهزاء بعباد
الله يكون ترك شيئا مما
علمه في كتاب الله وسنه
نبيه صلى الله عليه وسلم عليهم اجمعين
الصلاه
والسلام فيكون بذلك
جاهلا يقول
تعالى انما التوبه على الله للذين يعملون
السوء بجهاله ثم يتوبون من قريب فاولئك
يتوب الله عليهم وكان الله عليما
حكيما ايش المقصود هنا بجهاله ما قال بجهل
قال
بجهاله ومصدر عصيان الله والجهل بالله
سبحانه
وتعالى لذلك
ياتي هذه مقدمه مهمه لفهم الايات
التاليه ولفهم
بعض احاديث
واقوال للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
الصحابه تابعين مما قد يشكل على البعض مثل
قوله صلى الله عليه وسلم في حديث
عثمان من مات وهو يعلم انه لا اله الا
الله دخل الجنه من مات وهو
يعلم
هل يكفي العلم
يعني مجرد
المعلومه ابو جاهل ابو
طالب ابي بن
خلف بل فرعون
كلهم
يعلمون يعلمون ان موسى عليه السلام مرسل
من الله يعلمون ان محمدا صلى الله عليه
وسلم ارسله الله ليس
كذلك الله تعالى يقول فانهم لا
يكذبونك ولكن الظالمين بايات الله
يجحدون وقال الله تعالى حكايه عن
فرعون وجحدوا بها واستيقنتها انفسهم ظلما
وعلوا
استيقنتها فهؤلاء
يعلمون يعلمون ان لا اله الا الله يعلمون
ذلك فما معنى قول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم من مات وهو يعلم انه لا اله الا الله
دخل الجنه ايش معنى هذا
الكلام العلم هنا بالمعنى
الشرعي ليس بالمعنى اللغوي المعنى الشرعي
الذي ياتي
معه ياتي معه العمل
الذي مقتضاه
العمل فان العالم في لغه القران والعالم
في لغه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم هو الذي
يعمل
بعلمه وطالما
ردد الشاعر العلماء قول الشاعر وعالما
بعلمه لم
يعملا معذب من قبل باد الوثن والمقصود هنا
بالعالم
العالم اللغوي في لغه العرب عالم لكن في
لغه الشرع في لغه القران في لغه السنه لا
ليس عالم العالم هو الذي يعمل بما يعلم
هذا عالم لذلك اكتفى النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم بذكر العلم قال من مات وهو يعلم انه
لا اله الا الله دخل الجنه لانه يكون ع
عاملا
بذلك يكون
عمل يكون عمل بلا اله الا الله بشروط لا
اله الا الله واركان لا اله الا الله
وواجباتها
ومقتضياتها ومن ذلك العمل الذي يعلم
شرعا انه لا اله الا الله فانه عبد الله
لا محاله كن عابدا
لله
ولذلك يطلق على ابليس مع كثره معلوماته
انه
جاهل
جاهل فالعالم في القران هو بهذا المعنى
فمنه قول الله تعالى افمن
يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من ربك الحق كمن هو
اعمى هذه
الايه قيل انها انزل
في حمزه ابن عبد المطلب رضي الله عنه اسد
الله وابي
جهل والله عز وجل ضرب المثل
بينهما فقال افمن يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من
ربك
الحق هذا حمزه بن عبد
المطلب كمن هو اعمى وهو ابو جهل
ف الله عز وجل ذكر هذا وهذا يكون بعد
ايمان حمزه بعد اسلام حمزه رضي الله
عنه واسلام حمزه معلوم
الزمن فيكون هذا قبل العشر من السنه
العاشره من
النبوه بعد السابعه انزلت هذه السوره
قوله تعالى افمن
يعلم هو حمزه رضي الله عنه حمزه ابن عبد
المطلب
يعلم وابو جهل كان يعلم لغه لكن شرعا كان
جاهلا
بذلك مفهوم الكلام يعني لذلك يقال افمن
كان افمن يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من
ربك
يعني هو الذي يعلم ويعمل بمقتضى هذا
العلم فكذلك
الشان في جميع
القران
ف من
ذلك انه علم شرعا ما انزله الله فكان
عالما بالمعنى الشرعي
فدخل بعلمه الجنه وهذا معنى من مات وهو
يعلم انه لا اله الا الله دخل الجنه بعض
الناس فهم هذا بالمفهوم
اللغوي قال لك المهم الواحد يؤمن
بقلبه حتى لو ما حكى لا اله الا الله لكن
مات وهو يعلم لذلك لا يجوز تكفير الكفار
الذين يموتون على الكفر لماذا لانه ممكن
امن
بقلبه اذا فرعون مؤمن بقلبه وابو جاهل
مؤمن بقلبه وابو لهب وجميع الناس مؤمنون
بقلوبهم ما شاء الله يعني نادر جدا الذي
كفر هذا كلام لا يقبله العلماء ولا يقبله
عاقل بل الذي يستيقن
بقلبه
ولا يذعن بلسان
وبالعمل فانه كافر لا يمكن ان يكون
مسلما الاسلام لابد منه من اتباع
متابعه يقول افمن يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من
ربك الحق كمن هو
اعمى هذا طبعا استفهام قد سبق
مثله وهذا الذي يسمى عند علماء اللغه
علماء البلاغه بالاستفهام الانكار
الاستفهام الانكاري ما هو الاستفهام
الانكاري الاستفهام
الانكاري الذي نضع مكانه النفي حروف النفي
فاذا استقام المعنى فهو استفهام انكاري
فمثلا افمن يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من ربك
الحق كمن هو اعمى نشيل الاستفهام ونحط
محله النفي فنقول
من يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من ربك الحق ليس
كالاعمى استقام المعنى استقام هذا اسمه
استفهام انكاري يعني الله تعالى ينكر هذا
بشكل الاستفهام وهذا ابلغ من النفي المجرد
لماذا كانه يقول اسال اي واحد ما يمكن
اتلاك
عاقل يعترف او يقول ان الاعمى مثل الذي
يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من ربك الحق فهو
اسلوب بلاغي اسلوب بلاغي وابلغ من مجرد
النفي ف المقصود هنا
نفي المشابهه
والمماثله بين الذي يعلم
والاعمى ونفهم من هذا
ايضا ان الذي
يعلم والاعمى الاعمى في كتاب الله كثيرا
ما يطلق ويراد به ماذا يراد به
الكفار وكذلك الصم نقول تعالى انما يستجيب
الذين
يسمعون السمع الشرعي ليس السمع اللغوي
السمع اللغوي لكن الذي يسمع ولا يستجيب
فشرع هذا كال
كالعصا تماما وجوك
عدمه فقوله
تعالى افمن يعلم انما انزل اليك لاحظ
الفاء هنا والفاء هذه حرف
عطف فكانه يقول بناء على ما
سبق المثال الذي سلف
ذكره قوله تعالى انزل من السماء ماء فسالت
اويه بقدر
فاحتمل السيل زبد الرابيه ومما يوقدون
عليه في النار ابتغاء حليه او متاع زبد
مثله كذلك يضرب الله الحق والباطل فاما
الزبد فيذهب جفاء واما ما ينفع الناس
فيمكث في الارض كذلك يضرب الله الامثال
للذين استجابوا لربهم الحسنى والذين لم
يستجيبوا له لو ان لهم ما في الارض جميعا
ومثله معه لافتدوا به اولئك لهم سوء
الحساب وماواهم جهنم وبئس المهاد بناء على
هذا افمن يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من ربك
الحق كمن هو
اعمى طبعا لا طبعا لا يقول تعالى انما
يتذكر اولو
الالباب اولو الالباب اولو
هنا
هذا يسمى اسم موصول هذا اسم
موصول
و او هو اسم
اشاره ويقول الالباب مضاف الى الالباب وهو
جمع
لب
قولو بمعنى اصحاب
الالباب
اصحاب اللب الذي هو
العقل يقال لب الشيء الذي
هو
محتواه محتوى الشيء الذي يكون في داخل
الشيء محتواه هذا اسمه
لب لب المساله يعني محتوى
المساله
ولب فلان
يعني عقله لان ما الرجل انما هو
بعقله فقوله تعالى اولو الالباب يعني
اصحاب
العقول اصحاب
العقول
الاصل المعنى الشرعي اذا كنا نقرا القران
الاصل المعنى
الشرعي
فالعقل في لغه الشرع هو الذي
يعلم ان ما انزل الى صاح الى النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم هو الحق هذا هو العقل
الشرعي مهما كان الانسان ذكيا
فطنا
ويكفر
فهذا لا عقل
له مهما كان
الانسان حاد البصر اذا كان
لا يرى ان هذا الخلق ويرى ايات الله فهذا
اعمى
شرعا من كان يسمع وان كان يسمع دبيب
النمل
ولكن لا يؤديه هذا السمع الى الايمان
بالقران بكتب الله بكلام الله بشرائع الله
فهذا
اصم الذي لا
ينطق بالحق ولا يامر بالمعروف ولا ينهى عن
المنكر مهما كان بليغ مرن اللسان فانه
ماذا هذا
يكون
ابكم
ف هذا بالمعنى الش
اما بالمعنى اللغوي واضح انه يعني لذلك
ينفي الله سبحانه وتعالى السمع هذول ما
يسمع ما يبصر صم بكو عمي
لماذا لانهم لم
ينتفعوا بهذه في الاخره انتفاع
حقيقي فولو الالباب يعني اصحاب
العقول ولا يتذكر انما يتذكر اولو الالباب
يعني اصحاب
العقول وسياتي كذلك في القلب نفي القلب
واثبات القلب يقول تعالى الذين امنوا
وتطمئن قلوبهم بذكر
الله الا بذكر الله تطمئن القلوب طيب
والقلوب التي لا تطمئن بذكر الله وجودها
كالعدم كانها غير موجوده اصلا يعني ما حق
ان يقال له قلب
فهو يطمئن بذكر الله والقلب الذي لا يطمئن
بذكر الله هذا ليس قلبا
لادم هذا قلب وحوش هذا قلب وحش هذا ليس
قلب بني
ادم هذا هو
المعنى في كثير من الايات فقوله تعالى
افمن يعلم انما انزل اليك من ربك الحق كمن
هو اعمى طبعا ليسوا
سواء ليسوا سواء لا في الدنيا ولا في
الاخره ولا يمكن ان يكونوا سواء عند اصحاب
الايمان ولا عند اصحاب الكفر الذين يكفرون
بالله فانهم
يستحقر اهل
الاسلام الذين يؤمنون به هذا شيء طبيعي
الانسان يستحقر من
يضاده ولا
محاله لابد يستحقر من كان على ضد ما هو
عليه وعلى ضد ما يستحسنه وما
يستسيغه ف ليسوا سواء عند الله وليسوا
سواء في كتاب الله وليسوا سواء مصيرا
مصيرهم ليس سواء وكذلك عند عباد الله
الصالحين فانهم لا
سوون بين هؤلاء
وهؤلاء ليسوا سواء بل
يختلفون ييقول تعالى انما يتذكر اولو
الالباب
شخص لا
يحسن كثيرا من
الفهم شخص لا يحسن كثيرا من الفهم يعني
ابلد
الذهن لكن يؤمن بالله واليوم
الاخر هذا
ايش هذا من اول الالباب من اولي الالباب
وشخص
ذهنه من حدته يخرق
القماص ويكفر بالله
هذا ليس له عقل في كتاب
الله
وكذلك رجل عالم متقن للعلم الشرعي
متقن لكن لا يعمل بعلمه
ورجل يعني يدوب ويحسن الفرائض لكن يخشى
الله هذا صاحب عقل رزين والذي يقال له
عالم في لغه الناس هذا جاهل هذا جاهل
وعقله
ضعيف نكتفي بهذا الق
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين 19 سوره
الر 19 سه
الر الله سبحانه
وتعالى
‏is the one who
knows that what has come to you from
your lord is the truth is he the
one who is
blind rather it is
only the people of
intellect that will tru be
of now this ver
الله سبحانه
وتعالى and gives a different definition
to what people commonly
define a person of knowledge as being
and a person of ignorance as being a
person who can see and a person who is
blind
of
‏customarily
customarily
we agree that a person a blind person is
someone who cann physically see right
who does not possess
vision the capacity to
see but that is not necessarily the
meaning
in the legislation the legislative
meeting ‏a person who is blind
someone who cann see with any
consequence the miracles the signs of
allah and use his sight to recognize
that allah is worthy of worship alone
without any
partners likewise in our you know
customarily in our language we
understand that a person of intelligence
someone who able
to who someone of intellect
‏and a person low intelligence someone
lacking in that
however
islam
we inell inell are in قران
with that definition
is those who
‏and learn from his messengers and
implement learn these are people of
intelligence even if customarily we
would not view them as being very
intelligent and vice versa a person who
is incredibly intelligent linguistically
speaking customarily
intelligent memor well a strong strong
etc
‏wor الله سبحانه وتالى are in
are قران الله سبحانه
وتالى who disb heers to them as being
people who are
de ‏they can hear just fine but
their
hearing was no consequence in here with
الله سبحانه وتالى their vision was no
consequence their intellect was of no
consequence therefore it is as
if it was non
exist and this is for us
learn ‏with regards
to way that الله سبحانه وتالى speak the
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم speak
for صلى الله عليه
وسلم do you know who the bankrupt
is who is a bankrupt
person فينا
مال له ولا
متاع has no proper we view to be a
person
bankrupt we understand that the عليه
وسلم
resurrection mountains of
good ‏yet he as well has
many moments of transgression against
others and so those whom he transgress
against will be given of his good deeds
until he has no more good deeds
left and then he will be given of their
bad deeds and placed into the fire this
is a person who bankrupt
bankrupt legis
بلام الله سبحانه
وتالى
bankrupt and so here الله سبحانه وتالى
يعلم العلم
knowledge in this ver number 19 the one
who
knows so the one who knows here what's
meant by the one who knows is a believer
‏he saying is the one who knows that
what has come to you from your lord is
the truth the one who blind what me
by blind here blind meaning a person who
is a
disbeliever this is a person who
considered
blind even if they can see very
well
bl الله عليه وسل
‏they are
considered
people sound vision speaking in a in a
we speaking about vision which is vision
of the heart insight and so he says is
the one who knows knowledge here what's
meant by it
is
الله سبحانه
وتعالى this person is considered a
person of ignorance they not considered
person of
knowledge
knowledge obedience of
allah
‏ign
الله of how much person
knows
understand whatever whatever their iq
score is
whatever
قران
الله
قران dis
الله regardless of how many facts a
person memor facts and you know
information that's not the yard stick of
knowledge yard stick of knowledge and
the measurement of knowledge is
implementation and so الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏and those who are most virtuous from
the people of obedience from the muslims
from the believers are those who know
most and implement more of allah's
legislation the to do that is
more messenger said
‏and
so he say سبحانه وتالى
here he tells us is the one who knows me
by
knowledge thear الله سبحانه وتالى wors
الله
اللهصلى الله عليه
وسلم tr
‏and the
truly blind are those who
cann those who do not worship allah
those who do note allah those
disobedient those who do not
believe in allah and his messengers he
says it is only the people of true int
that
will
remember
resp سبحه
وى
‏in and so for this
reason we see that a person could
be person could in قران
in narration certain verses and
they misst so for instance ‏there a
narration
صحح that the propet صل الله عليه وسلم
said whoever knowing that none is
rightfully worship but allah will enter
paradise who dies
knowing is it enough for a person to
only
know
الله is worthy of worship is that enough
to enter
paradise well if we are speaking about
linguistic knowledge
meaning it's just something that they
know but they don't implement
it
not الله سبحانه وى tells ‏that was knew
that he reed it outwardly and apparently
why out of arrogance and we agree all of
us muslims non muslims we all agree that
pharaoh is
the antithesis of those who enter
paradise and
so what's meant here is knowledge quic
knowledge knowledge that is as defined
in the قران
‏and that is the one
who
knows and
implements that
knowledge yes whoever knows in that
sense that none is rightfully worship
but allah yes will enter paradise of
course is the
believer and it is only those who know
that that will enter
paradise but it is not enough to just
have a fact to just memor a fact and
believe that you
‏acc
kind
sign
recn
قران
قران والمصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
‏n